hey guys we're at a rage room and i'm
freaking
[Music]
[Laughter]
pissed
[Music]
[Applause]
are you are you angry today i think
deep down i am i need to like
dig in and get it out but i think i do
have a little bit of rage
oh we've got rage today
so we came to uh what is this place
called dan
the rage factor ground or the rage
grounds in la
we've got a car we went all out we've
got a bunch
of knickknacks and hail mary's and uh we
of course brought the gatsby so
it's all going down today so i brought a
personal item
um printer that have caused me
many many many many rage moments
here's the weaponry by the way oh my god
sledgehammers bats
pipes oh god war swords
axes machetes heavy
no not heavy could kill someone today
you know i could take this whole room
out in the gatsby in like five seconds
which i'm tempted to do but okay let's
suit up and start smashing stuff
what did i get xl well right now it's
not even a fat issue it's a
camel toe issue okay i guess it fits
does it look like a camel toe situation
or no it's okay
no i don't see any right now
all right well this is the first i've
never had to give rules to a robot so
this is really fun
all right so these streams are going to
go over really quick you guys ready to
go
yes awesome let's do it all right let's
do this
what's first what should i do first i
mean do you want to just break stuff
like delicately
um let's start easy
[Music]
is that what you meant
[Music]
all right i'll just park this here for
now you know what you want to do you got
you know about all the rage
then uh would you please follow me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's for the wi-fi here's another
printer just let's take it out on the
[Applause]
printers
i man i've been waiting for this moment
this [ __ ] queen mary you're so smug
acting like you never had sex
she just had a miracle shave here throw
this small gas
virgin mary acting like she never had
sex what's wrong with having sex
i don't want to do laundry anymore mom
you can't tell me what's
i have to do my laundry
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you doing why are you so close
to the junk bro can he try to destroy
like a cop
and so it just goes straight uh
no no you missed okay
little cd there you go hey [ __ ] that up
dude
dan's got rage i got rage here's rage
boy
dad's angry dude he says he's not angry
but he is i'm gonna take a big crack at
this thing all right
um i think uh
i think dan should dedicate something to
all the times ethan was late
on fridays what come on
yeah i mean like i said i don't get mad
there's no rage in my heart at all
now that being said
seems angry he definitely seems angry
guys
now is this the first time you've ever
done this because
um i mean it's the first time i've ever
paid
[Music]
[Applause]
real last thing and i'll pass it off you
didn't [ __ ] listen to tupac
no i won't say it
i'd say we're not leaving until this
printer is totally [ __ ]
scrap metal
maybe this is a good one for zach oh
pickles does that not like pickles
[Music]
[ __ ] i hate crap man
keep going craft man will [ __ ] you dude
that man is [ __ ] too hard who's the
helmet boy
who's the hell
oh [ __ ]
are you angry oh my god i'm just so
freaking angry
oh [ __ ] bro that bottle didn't even
break
i feel pretty good stop dude that bottle
didn't even break and step it up
bro you can't go what's going on in show
the rage
there you go hey actually the printer
nothing even happened to it maybe you
can try okay and
for elo let's see what you got for the
printer
[Applause]
there it is there it is
pretty good review for hp
on your own dude your helmet's off i
can't help
all right love come on get your [ __ ]
together we're trying to break [ __ ]
all right you're good you're free
all right ian
please stand up
please stand up ian on buddy
all right let me take a couple swings on
this thing ela you want to swing on this
man that thing's strong sammy you want
to go eat [ __ ] while you're out here
oh damn
[Music]
there it is all right you know what i'm
sick of this thing giving a [ __ ] here
let's [ __ ] it up
all right you know what you know what
this isn't working
we need bigger guns
let me through a path for you real quick
okay go ahead not angry
damn not hungry at all just making sure
you got a nice clean suit
all right
all right i think you're good not angry
at all all right
[Music]
wait hold on i think i might be injured
i might be
okay i'm okay i wasn't sure what was the
damage
no this thing is here i'm coming for
another round on this [ __ ]
all right here we go
what what's up
oh no
did we [ __ ] break the cat
no no i'm just stuck on something
av you angry it was my [ __ ]
you know what i think about the chair
you know what i think about the chair
do you smell burning electric sonics
no i definitely do you think it's the
gas possible
you might want to shut it off yeah i
think it might be from one of those very
possible
this thing is humming like a hummingbird
yes oh damn oh damn
all right all right all right all right
all right
all right dude wow simp forever
i'm gonna take one more crack at these
printers brother talk to me
[Music]
all right here we go pray for me
[Music]
pray for me
the gatsby is undefeated i just took out
like hundreds of pounds of junk
and killed it all oh
i thought i saw a little smoke do you
see this oh there's a storage
thing in there i
i could have just been the dust and
debris i mean the check
engine light's
[Music]
all green do you any do you know any
gatsby repairman
we got a check break here check light
all right so we got a car here this is
the bonus level on street fighter oh
love's in the back
all right let's see what this thing can
do like seriously
i mean [ __ ] it
all right one more one more for me
yo this car can't even handle the gatsby
though
all right baby godspeed to you let's try
to get that bumper off
the [ __ ] gatsby is unstoppable
oh my god
oh look look look look the check breaks
off it's about we're back on green
it's back on green all right let's let's
leave this sweet baby alone for now
okay can i punch this out yo they got
parking tickets on this [ __ ] already
pay your [ __ ] ticket
what you got it
i don't like this thing
hey love getting a little close to the
action aren't we
oh this thing is on neutral dude this
thing is rolling
oh [ __ ] dude
nothing just tired
that one's awesome dude dan mr peace and
love
that's safety glass no joke
let's see what these this rage place is
hiding in their trunks
oh my god it's a bunch of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] in the trunk let's see
what's under the hood
bob can you not like
you ride my [ __ ] swing zone bro
hey you guys want to try to get the the
uh engine open we never got in there
[Music]
so
let's get in that trunk boys they got
bodies for sure
i'm sure of it
and we got this
oh no no
we're just so close
[Applause]
i think we're uh just about out of time
here any last uh
jesus well still we got to get this
[ __ ]
open
all right all right we're done
oh i got a
[Applause]
he's
oh you weren't supposed to break today
jesus how did who did this to you what
happened
you pushed me from behind what happened
bro
how did this happen how could this
happen to our beloved bot with such
great
balance he the balance of this thing is
unbelievable how did it fall and break
the screen i just don't understand it
lovebot lovebot
no no
no everybody
it's not your fault all right we're
gonna have to take him out back and
take the gatsby over him one time we're
gonna have to put this thing out of its
misery
oh lovebot how could this happen when
you have such amazing balance i just
don't understand
what the balance of this robot how could
it possibly ever fall and break
this literally doesn't make any sense
why did this happen why did this happen
why is this happening love you were
supposed to have perfect balance
you were supposed to have perfect
balance love
no why is this happening to you
no no no no
you were supposed to die you were
supposed to have perfect balance
oh no no
love oh
oh no we barely knew you
oh why do the good always die young love
what why did the good always die oh
it's okay go to the light love go to the
light
hold my hand
sweet prince
[Music]
you